foreign
produced and aired a four-part
documentary called we need to talk about
Cosby and I haven't seen it I don't plan
to see it and if this clip which went
viral this week after the series aired
on the BBC is any indication then
there's no reason for me to change that
policy I will not be watching it in the
clip we're treated to some insight from
sonali rashitwar who is a non-binary sex
therapist who goes by they he pronouns
which means that uh she's a female so
her personal pronouns are all of the
pronouns except the right ones so she'll
take any of them as long as it's not
right
um and if those credentials don't
impress you though I should also mention
that she is very fat
she's a very fat person and I can say
that because that's how she identifies
herself she calls herself on her website
the fat sex therapist
and the website uh speaking of also
contains this description of her work it
says this
Sona Lee rashitwar is an award-winning
clinical social worker sex therapist
adjunct lecturer and Grassroots
organizer based in Philly they are a
they are a superset wait superset I
think I might have put them they are a
super queer bisexual non-binary
therapist and co-owner of radical
Therapy Center specializing in treating
sexual trauma diet trauma racial or
immigrant trauma and South Asian family
abuse
okay so if you suffered from North Asian
family abuse I guess you're out of luck
I guess
uh now most of the sounds like nonsense
to me but she does deserve credit at
least for her efforts to fight diet
trauma I mean as we can see she has
clearly been extremely successful in
staving off trauma related to dieting so
if you're worried about being
traumatized by dieting she's definitely
the person you want to talk to about
that
um but that isn't really the point we
need to focus on
um especially because her website is
absolutely filled with this kind of
gibberish here's just one more sampling
is what it says
sexuality is morphed by the pressures of
compounding oppressions which is why I
offer solution focused workshops that
affirm the colonized experience and
contribute to the radical imagination of
our d-colonial sexual Futures we must
unlearn the ways that we have been
forced to exist within what is
considered normal and begin to imagine
the ways that we can flourish outside of
those pressurized systems by aggregating
individual forms of sexual resistance
I'm able to weave together workshops
explaining broader ideas of collective
sexual Liberation centering
conversations around pleasure and body
Liberation we can better imagine how Joy
will lead us to Revolution
now that all reads as if it was written
by some kind of random woke word
generator
um leftist buzzwords are combined with
academic sounding jargon and weird
psychobabble with little attempt made to
form them into actual coherent sentences
which is how do you end up with gems
like the phrase aggregating individual
forms of sexual resistance whatever
sexual resistance is supposed to be I'm
not quite sure how it can be aggregated
this is what happens when a person with
an IQ of 95 uses a thesaurus to try and
make her writing sound more intelligent
it's a it's a common Pitfall of a
certain type of dumb person where they
are given to believe that in order to
sound intelligent you must be
unintelligible
which is
like the opposite of how it's supposed
to work
but this is perhaps more information
than you needed needed to know about
this person but it does help to put the
clip into context
though the context won't make it any
less horrifying than it is uh listen
if we actually grappled with the fact
that sex negativity is what causes this
type of behavior
then we could
create a world where in a sex
idyllically sex positive World someone
is able to pay conscious women to come
and be drugged so that I can get my cake
out my my fetish on having sex with
unconscious people there's a consensual
way to do that
oh there you see Bill Cosby he wasn't a
serial rapist that she as she explains
he wasn't that uh or if he was it wasn't
his fault he was the victim of a world
that isn't sex positive enough
if only he had had an outlet to as she
says get his kink out then he wouldn't
have been forced to drug and rape so
many women
now this is of course disgusting and
depraved it's no wonder that a woman
with no concept of physical health would
also have such deluded ideas about what
is sexually and morally healthy as well
but she does help us to see I think two
important points first
um first point is this that we need to
get back to King shaming they were told
we're not supposed to King Shane they
don't shame anyone's Kink or they're
fetish I don't shame it no no no
actually uh actually we should there
should be a lot of Shame being heaped on
many of these Kinks and fetishes that
are that are you know uh celebrated
these days in our culture we have this
notion that a person's Kinks You know
their sexual habits and desires are
automatically above criticism the worst
thing we could ever do is critique or
interrogate someone else's sexual
proclivities
sonali is simply standing at the logical
endpoint of that idea
if we mustn't Kink shame if we must
pretend that all sex is good or at least
morally neutral so it's neutral so long
as it's allegedly consensual then even
rape becomes its own as she says Kink
that just needs a healthy Outlet
but this is not true
um the premise is fatally flawed
sex is not a morally neutral playing
field how could it be
okay sex is an interaction with another
human being
there's there's no interaction to begin
with that's morally neutral
but in this case it's the most intimate
sort of interaction it involves the most
intimate sort of physical contact you
are engaging with someone who is in the
most vulnerable state both physically
and emotionally and spiritually and in
every other way uh sex is an act laid in
with consequence
potentially serious consequences
of course there are proper ways to go
about it and improper ways it's not just
a forum to get your kinks out
the problem with many Kinks that we are
supposed to accept or even celebrate
these days including the one that the
fat sex therapist is talking about
though certainly not just that one is
that they don't respect the dignity and
god-given value of the other person
involved
okay so often these are things that are
degraded and disgusting and perverse
there are proper ways and improper ways
of interacting with someone in even a
casual environment but sex is not casual
no matter how much we try to pretend
otherwise
and so if there's a right and wrong way
for even casual interactions between
humans to go about to go then how much
more must that be the case for sexual
interactions
there are right and wrong ways a kink uh
may be performed consensually but it can
still be deeply disordered and degraded
and therefore we should criticize it
even more we should ask why okay if you
have a weird gross sexual fetish
you should be asking yourself why you
have it what is it about this depraved
activity that you find so appealing
you see we live in a society that is
obsessed with desire
you know we're always it's we all we
care about is what someone desires what
they want so we're obsessed with desire
and yet we're so incredibly incurious
about it at the same time we never ask
why a person has a certain desire all we
know is that they desire what they
desire and so they should go off and try
to attain whatever they desire
but there are some desires that should
not be pursued in fact there are many
such desires and those desires are
warning signs in the case of a desire to
you know have sex with unconscious
people as this woman is talking about
the warning side is more like an alarm
Bell blaring at a hundred decibels
indicating that something is deeply
wrong in the person's mind and soul we
should be investigating what is wrong
rather than telling people to ignore it
in the Mindless pursuit of satisfying
whatever disgusting urge enters into
their head
second Point all of this
begins to make sense as soon as we
realize that consent based morality okay
morality that is merely consent based
is not just wrong but catastrophic to
any culture that tries to adopt it case
in point our culture
there has to be more to morality
especially sexual morality than mere
consent
obviously all sexual activity must be
consensual obviously it's a horrible
evil to force yourself on someone
violating their consent but the problem
is that that is where our culture wants
to end the conversation
but it should be the ending it's just
the beginning of the conversation
about what entails you know a healthy
um good sex life
okay but but what our culture says that
if the sex is consensual then that's all
there is to say about it there is
nothing else to say about it
all sex is good so long as both people
or however many people verbally agree to
participate in it the flaw in this idea
is that it it emphasizes
it's not that it's not that it
emphasizes consent but that it only
cares about consent
consent is the beginning and the end
and that's how you wind up with people
like Sona Lee trying to find a
consensual way for men like Bill Cosby
to sexually violate unconscious women
that's indeed how you end up with a lot
a lot lots of disordered harmful
damaging sexual behavior that is
nonetheless accepted because it's
consensual
what we need to finally understand is
that consent is not the one and only
consideration while all non-consensual
sex is automatically evil it doesn't
follow that all consensual sex is
automatically good
because sex can still be degrading
demeaning dehumanizing even when the
participants are engaged in the act by
choice
we see that consent on its own is a
flimsy and insufficient framework for
sexual morality
this is also why people will you know
very often will these days will engage
in in consensual sex with some random
person that they met you know on Tinder
or whatever
and then they'll wake up the next day
feeling regret
this happens all the time they agreed
they consented and yet now they regret
it
in fact a person engaged in consensual
sex
not only regret it but could wake up
feeling used and exploited because they
were used and exploited
they consented to being used and
exploited but they were still used and
exploited
and they used and exploited their
partner in equal measure that's what a
lot of consensual uh sex and casual sex
that's what it is it is the mutual
agreement
for two people to use and exploit each
other and then discard them so you've
got consent there's no question about it
but does that mean we can't we can't say
anything else about to criticize that
you're treating each other this way
like maybe it's not good for you maybe
it's not good for the other person
maybe this is not a path to fulfillment
and happiness in life
the thing is a situation like that
neither person was raped but they did
indulge in something shallow Loveless
and degrading and having casual sex they
allowed a stranger to use them as a
glorified masturbatory Aid they feel
embarrassed and vulnerable now they feel
hollow they feel despair they feel
regret
these feelings are inevitable
when you divorce sex from Love and from
devotion and from fidelity
and from Concepts like dignity
and that should be the framework rather
than merely asking whether the sex is
consensual we should ask whether it is
loving whether it respects the Dignity
of the other person
and the great thing is that this
framework
will will obviously include consent
but then it goes
much farther beyond that as it needs to
this is something that's obvious to me
and obvious to many people
but of course to someone like Sona Lee
who makes it her whole life and her
whole business to talk about sex she
can't see this Insight at all and that
is why she is today finally cancer
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign